[Musique]
bonjour à tous bonjour Geneviève
darriosec bonjour merci d'être avec nous
ce matin et nous sommes au cœur de ce
36e Téléthon qu'est-ce que vous diriez à
la place qui est la vôtre ministre en
charge des personnes en situation de
handicap sur ce cache changer
précisément le Téléthon sur le regard
que l'on porte sur la différence sur les
personnes qui sont souvent en position
de handicap ou d'invalidité à cause de
leur maladie bien voilà le Téléthon a
permis de mettre le focus sur certains
types de handicaps liés à ces maladies
génétiques
et c'est important parce que cela
rejaillit aussi sur la vision que l'on
peut avoir de toutes ces personnes en
situation de handicap même si tous les
handicaps ne sont pas liés à des
maladies génétiques il y a une grande
diversité dans les types de handicap la
première fois que l'on m'a montré à la
télévision la différence qu'on est
est-ce que c'est un pas aussi vers
l'inclusion des personnes qui qui
souffrent de handicap ce qui est
important c'est que ça permet de porter
un regard de montrer aussi les
difficultés que peuvent avoir dans la
vie quotidienne les personnes en
situation de handicap la nécessité de
l'inclusion de ces personnes dans notre
société
l'inclusion à l'école l'inclusion dans
le monde du travail l'inclusion dans
notre société dans la culture dans le
monde sportif donc je crois que cette
journée du Téléthon a pu aussi au-delà
de ce qu'elle porte pour la recherche
pour les maladies génétiques à aussi
ouvert le regard des Français vis-à-vis
du handicap alors le regard des Français
et aussi de la générosité car le
Téléthon ce sont d'abord des dons privés
même exclusivement 86 millions d'euros
avaient été récoltés l'an dernier on
espère que cette année ce sera encore
davantage mais à côté de cela que fait
l'état pour lui aussi encourager la
recherche contre les maladies rares ou
aider les personnes qui souffrent de ces
maladies alors d'abord indirectement
l'État participe au Téléthon puisque les
dons sont défiscalisés à hauteur de
70%, c'est donc une
participation de l'État qui n'est pas
neutre et puis ensuite bien entendu il y
a eu beaucoup de programme de recherche
en matière de santé ces programmes se
poursuivront et ils ne peuvent être et
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
qu'il y ait une complémentarité entre ce
que porte les chercheurs qui travaillent
dans le cadre du Génopole et ce que
porte la recherche française dans les
autres secteurs alors vous vous occupez
aussi particulièrement de l'aide aux
personnes handicapées on l'entendait
dans le journal le budget de la Sécurité
sociale a été définitivement adopté hier
soir à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que le budget spécifique en
faveur des personnes handicapées lui va
augmenter parce qu'on sait que le
ministère de la Santé a fixé priorité
l'hôpital la prévention la lutte contre
les déserts médicaux qu'en est-il de
l'aide au handicapés
très heureuse que ce budget de la
Sécurité sociale ait été votée parce que
le budget consacré au handicap à
augmenter augmente de 730 millions
d'euros passe à plus de 14 milliards
d'euros sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale et va permettre outre le fait
des revalorisations des personnels va
permettre également de mettre en oeuvre
des actions concrètes des unités pour
autistes le développement de de soutien
au polyhandicap enfin des actions
concrètes et je dois dire que pour les
budgets pour le handicap nous avons
aussi une grande une partie du budget de
l'État qui est consacré au handicap à
hauteur également de 14 milliards et
demi d'euros donc et qui est en
augmentation cette année de 800 millions
d'euros pour en revenir aux maladies
rares qui sont donc au cœur de de du
Téléthon ce que vous demande aujourd'hui
ce qui aident les personnes qui
souffrent de ces handicaps du assez
maladies excusez-moi c'est précisément
de les aider eux de les aider elles ces
personnes je cite ce que dit la
présidente du Téléthon l'aide à domicile
pour les personnes en grande dépendance
elle a des spécificités dit-elle
incomprises et négligée qu'est-ce que
l'État apporte comme réponse à cette
demande à ce cri d'alerte même des
associations qui qui aident les malades
alors nous avons bien sûr deux types
d'aidants les aidants professionnels et
les aidants familiaux les aidants
professionnels ce dont vous me parlez
sont effectivement des personnes nous
avons des difficultés des difficultés de
recrutement dans ces métiers parce que
ce sont des métiers complexes
quelquefois difficiles
quelquefois peut-être insuffisamment
rémunéré donc il est envisagé de pour
vivre l'augmentation de la rémunération
de ces métiers puisque
nous passerons à 23 euros de l'heure en
2023 pour les personnes pour les
services d'aide à domicile nous allons
également travailler sur un service
autonomie qui va regrouper différents
types de services il y aura des heures
des rémunérations complémentaires pour
des actes complexes ou chez des
personnes nécessitant des des soins plus
complexes donc toute une série de
mesures sont mises en oeuvre pour
améliorer la rémunération de ces
personnes et puis à côté je crois qu'il
faut que nous améliorions la formation
et également le mode de travail la
structuration du travail de ces
personnes mais ça c'est les les aidants
professionnels eux-mêmes qui doivent
travailler je crois à cette
structuration du travail parce que ce
sont des heures hachées dans la journée
et une difficulté d'organisation du
travail
à mettre sa part pour rendre ses métiers
plus attractifs qui ne le sont
aujourd'hui puisque encore une fois on
manque de personnel et parfois ce sont
les familles elles-mêmes qui se
retrouvent à devoir s'occuper de malades
qui ont de grands alors oui améliorer le
statut et améliorer la rémunération et
les conditions de travail des aidants
professionnels et également tenir compte
des aidants familiaux et là il y avait
un plan pour les aidants qui a été qui
se termine
en 2022 et avec Jean-Christophe combe
nous avons relancé nous allons relancer
une stratégie pour les aidants afin qui
consiste à améliorer la conciliation
entre le travail et le la présence à
domicile qui consiste aussi à améliorer
les conditions pour le répit de ces
aidants c'est à dire qu'il se repose
qu'il puisse voilà prendre des moments
ce que vous demande précisément l'AFM
par exemple c'est
ces aidants si je peux me permettre
cette expression voilà où il se il se
régénérer et puis également de faire en
sorte que l'inclusion scolaire
l'inclusion dans les crèches l'inclusion
dans les centres de loisirs des enfants
en situation de handicap permettent à
ces aidants familiaux et bien de pouvoir
avoir une activité professionnelle ou
une activité personnelle qui leur permet
ben voilà tout simplement de d'aider
dans de meilleures conditions alors ce
Téléthon 2022 il coïncide aussi avec la
Journée internationale des personnes
handicapées c'est aujourd'hui ce 3
décembre en France on estime à 12
millions au total des personnes qui
souffrent de handicap plus ou moins
lourd et vous l'un de vos combats si
j'ose dire c'est l'inclusion de ces
personnes dans le monde du travail
est-ce que les choses bougent on sait
que beaucoup d'employeurs rechignent à
employer des personnes qui ont des
handicaps est-ce que il y a une
évolution il y a une évolution
importante entre en 2017 nous avions un
taux de chômage chez les personnes
handicapées à 19%. aujourd'hui les a
13%. il est encore beaucoup trop élevé
par rapport à la population générale
mais nous poursuivons ce travail qui est
un travail à faire auprès des employeurs
pour leur montrer que embaucher une
personne en situation de handicap ne
nuit pas leur entreprise au contraire et
faire en sorte aussi de donner confiance
aux personnes en situation
sur les pénuries parfois dans le dans le
recrutement les pénuries de personnel ça
profite indirectement aux personnes
handicapées absolument parce que les
employeurs et les recruteurs ont été
contraints d'élargir le spectre de leurs
recherches ils ont découvert
que et bien chez les personnes en
situation de handicap il y avait des
compétences et que bien voilà avec un
peu de formation et bien c'était des ça
devenait des des collaborateurs
collaborateurs absolument efficaces dans
les entreprises Geneviève
avec ministre délégué aux personnes en
situation de handicap vous accompagnez à
votre place ce Téléthon 2022 pour cette
journée encore sur France 2 36 37 on le
rappelle c'est la suite de Télématin et
la suite donc du Téléthon merci à tous
les deux